okay new game going against the t-rex
cannon down go you for for a change to
let in some variety even open Sicilian
and display the current variation I have
this line okay this is a bit bit of a
sideline but not too bad for black I
think I need to take and this is
actually the the classical Fisher versus
Pedro Petrosian game
hmm this looks a bit a bit uncomfortable
for black Queen a4 check now he needs to
stay in the center with the skin
check
right yeah but I don't have anything
really better than checking now after he
takes d5 I'm not sure Bishop takes d5 I
think I thought you couldn't play this
ok maybe you can might have six young ok
yeah it's a bit uncomfortable looking
for blanket with the King in the center
and I can always just grab the drip pan
with a healthy slight advantage ok
cannot be too bad to place a the rook
opposite the came here
maybe it's not too too dramatic for
black and this is what a pretty good
development going okay we should be up
g5 this is an idea why should just wish
where should position this Bishop go now
maybe this actually really threatens
Bishop f6 likes pawn structure would be
very weak but its opposite colors
bishops if you look at you should have
six sent all right
not exactly what I expected
now maybe can go just kingi cell next
smooth yeah like a son yeah it's not
comfortable but maybe it's a it's still
hope halfway ok trying Bishop e3 let's
have two against one on the queenside
which might be helpful but it's not
immediately obvious how it should be
helpful yeah I think it's changing would
brought nothing maybe this is a bit
annoying okay should either exchange now
I guess so
I'm a bit quicker here on the queenside
but he's got those this night moves here
which are quite um quite annoying
maybe I should just attack in 16 ok
keeps playing moves I didn't expect and
you put keeps playing them instantly
this looks like some pressure still ok
I'm done on time not quite sure why is
going with this 25 I know I can if I can
just take here of course then drop this
back to see three
okay now I can you can play even deform
who interesting ok and then 93 is not a
good move yeah x of course an issue
I'm still trying to do something here
playing for win maybe this is completely
unwarranted very likely it is especially
considering the time
time morning yeah quite annoying adore
this is quite some some square here I
can just take all I'm stupid
I'm very stupid me know where the where
is this night going
yeah maybe I should have been content
with some some normal move and just
trade this off to a draw which wouldn't
be too difficult but I wouldn't have
been now it's a so just bad position
when the night night only six
glad that this piece isn't lost maybe
this loss but trying to play in a way
that is not lost I will know I'm just
jealous you one alright quite young
resides just a completely crap game why
does this better yeah but I completely
misplayed this maybe it starts with all
this kind of move obviously it doesn't
bring any any benefits yeah blacks king
is active here in the center and the
lightest is nice to give checks and sand
and forks and so on but it's not has it
doesn't have a stable position yet yeah
well I intended to play Knight c3 but
then you can just go deform and maybe
rookie one check yeah it's still not not
a big deal to draw this this stuff here
but I was trying to too hard to do
something
yeah computer actually gives me an
advantage of them even after 97 buddies
be takes f5 was of course completely
idiotic rook takes e4 is a porn up at
the end rook takes you far funny the
tons of tons of frogs and at the end I
windy form so I've got an extra porn but
it's a draw anyway yeah but he takes a
five was just completely idiotic 1 1
minute is not much but I could my troop
takes before yeah but he takes a five is
obviously bad so all right bad game